I want to I want to really talk in
detail about having a career in film and
television because them because the big
difference between having a Korean film
and television with the studios in the
networks versus having a career as an
independent filmmaker or making your own
web series is simply the difference
between wealth and poverty financial
wealth and poverty because the studios
are the network's have the money and if
you're in the writers guild or the DGA
there are minimums guaranteed minimums
they you know it's you'll earn a lot
more money and that's great wealth is
very nice having a lot of money is very
nice but but so in terms of cracking
that it's just you must meet these
people face-to-face you must go where
they are and and because if you're in
you know East McKeesport Pennsylvania or
in Connecticut or in the Bay Area you
know you're just not going to run into
these people they're here they're here
in Los Angeles so the first step is you
move here and you meet as many people as
you can possibly meet and you learn how
to say in one sentence the thing that
legitimizes you so Fran and you and by
the way every studio network has a
fellowship a writing fellowship you can
enter those their most number for free
the Nichols fellowship also all the
studios and networks and agencies
monitor those if you win those it's a
big step in getting a career if you
wouldn't the ABC disney fellowship they
give you $50,000 and a career so so
that's the thing i would advocate for
everybody it's much better now than it
used to be when i was writing The
Twilight Zone companion and I saw a
photo of the crew and first of all they
were all in suit and tie which I thought
was very amusing for a crew and but
secondly they were all white males with
the except with it with the one
exception of the script girl who was a
white female and now you can be
african-american you can be a female and
be a showrunner you can you know yes
Hollywood is ages and rate and racist
and sexist but it's better than it used
to be it just is so and also by the way
anytime you encounter those kind of
problems you don't get defeated by them
you should say okay I'm gonna get around
that wall fir that wall I'll do that
wall I'm gonna break through that wall
I'm gonna it's it's irrelevant it's not
is relevant
it's an impediment but it shouldn't stop
you because there are plenty of people
who succeed despite those things and so
that's that's a big part of it - also -
you started out writing in your early
20s engage right well my first short
story I saw when I was 19 and I was
having gallery shows of my art with
photography when I was a teenager so in
my first radio play I wrote when I was
18 and it aired when I was 18 so I just
pretty fast out of the gate
so and I was writing my first book at 22
the twilight zone companion and I was
writing for TV by the time I was 22 or
23 yeah yeah how was that being so young
did you have the certainly it was great
oh yes well it was well I was very lucky
because when I was a kid the Twilight
Zone and Star Trek and outer limits the
original versions of those shows were
the things that made me want to be a
writer particularly television writer
when I was 13 I read a book called the
making of Star Trek it was the first
book I ever read about how to make a TV
show and in the first writer I ever saw
a person was Ray Bradbury he spoke at a
library when I was 10 so all of these
things start percolating in my mind and
when I was a kid I also got a visit as a
Christmas present I was given a visit
and Star Trek set and so I got I was
there for the filming of the last
episode of the original Star Trek I was
on the enterprise sets which was just
correct and so so I knew I should have
had a sense of calling I knew I would be
an artist or a writer from a very early
age I was drawing and writing and
reading science fiction voraciously and
comic books and watching TV and going to
movies so I was very lucky in that way
and so and I also also because I saw the
Ray Bradbury and Rod Serling
were writing books and movies and TV
shows I have that sensor you could go
opportunity between all through all
three and that was very useful to and
rate one thing that Ray said to me is
it's very important to to do all three
particularly keep writing books because
then they can't own you and no single
rejection can stop you so so Ray had a
lot of movies he brought that never got
made I have I have the script of the
Martian Chronicles that railroad for MGM
in 1963 it was gonna be the movie that
Gregory Peck and Robert monk and we're
gonna do right after to kill a
mockingbird it's a great script and it
never got me and I've got an original
copy of that signed by Ray and which I
read in little tiny pieces every day at
lunch when I was a producer on sliders
just to kind of take as long as possible
to read this wonderful script was great
who you mentioned Ray Bradbury being one
of your men yes or some of the other
mentors and in terms of you said you
observe people and there's good that
what did you actually observe with these
mentors that maybe they didn't
articulate to you as you saw this gene
secrets to their success yes
well I think two of the things that okay
here's the reason I'm a professional
writer as opposed to someone sitting in
a bar all day long bitter and saying
that and kind of point at evening going
though shows I should have been writing
for those shows and Hollywood sucks I
hate everything you know I should have
been that guy I just you know still
might be you know with the day is young
but but the but what it was was when I
was 16 my mother went to Sears and
bought this really weird piece of
furniture there was a table with two
beds that would go in a diet yeah right
angles to each other under you tuck him
under the table then you pull him out to
sleep on it was the weirdest damn thing
I've no idea where she why she bought it
was she putting a web living room of our
apartment but I also had an am/fm radio
built into that table and we don't had
am radios but never FM radios and so one
night when I was 16 I started twirling
the dial at about 10:00 at night on a
Friday and I started hearing something
amazing which was science fiction
writers talking about their craft and it
was a radio show called hour 25 and for
the first time I started hearing all the
writers I grew up reading Robert
Heinlein and Isaac Asimov and arthur c
clarke and Ray Bradbury and Theodore
sturgeon all these great science fiction
writers in Harlan Ellison talking about
writing and and and many of them in
Britain for Star Trek Ted sturgeon and
Harlan and Richard Matheson and and and
I started hearing them talk about
writing and Harlan was talking about
science we can write in workshop called
clarion Writers Workshop and was the
leading science fiction writing workshop
three and it was six weeks long 25
students at Michigan State University in
the summer and each week a different
famous science fiction writer who lived
with you in the dorms and you would
write like crazy and critique each
other's stories and I thought I want to
go to that so even though I was an art
student at UCLA I got enrolled in the
art school by mistake it was a clerical
error I never applied to that major but
I got a degree in it because it was you
know why not that's another story but
but when I was 19 I went to Clarion and
it was six very famous science fiction
writers and then I sold my first short
story but I also learned from those
writers the main thing I learned was
that they were just like me that if they
could do it I could was Roger Zelazny
Samuel R Delaney Joe Haldeman Kate
Wilhelm Damon Knight Gene Wolfe and and
Damon Knight one of the students asked
him which of us do you think will make
it as professional writers and he should
not have answered that question but he
did and even he's named several and they
all became very famous writers and I was
where the ones he thought would not make
it and the next day he bought my first
short story
pathology he was acting which taught me
first of all that no one can predict
your future no one has a right to rob
you of your future and he could not look
into my secret soul and see how
determined I was he could not look into
my heart and he couldn't even predict
the future 24 hours ahead and so so my
point my point is that if someone says
something negative you if they say
you're never gonna make it as a writer
say four words to them that will get
them to go away and those four words are
you're the Antichrist and and they'll go
away because no one has a right to take
away from you all they can say as I read
your script and from my point of view
this is where it's not working that's
all they can say they have no right to
say anything else but so so from meeting
those professional writers I sold my
first short story that was fifty bucks -
oh my first I was fifty bucks my next
sale was twenty thousand and that was
for the Twilight Zone companion that was
the advance and but but then when I got
back to UCLA
Ted sturgeon Theodore sturgeon was a
Star Trek writer a written great science
fiction books and novels that I grew up
reading he was teaching up
education class and as an undergrad I
wasn't allowed to take the adult
education classes but I thought well you
know hell with that it's tedsters I'm
gonna take it and so another rule I
would say is anything with disempowers
you ignore it
if there's rules they're set against you
ignore them just do what your heart
tells you to do as long as you don't
harm anyone you know you don't want to
be you know purchase well to others but
in that case I just signed up with class
and one of the and the teaching and Ted
became clearer sturgeon became one of my
mentors when I was 19 so there was a
there was a teaching assistant in the
inner sturgeons class and his name was
Michael Reeves and he'd just come out of
clearing in a year or two before me and
he had been riding professionally and he
was just trying to write an animation
for the networks and so we became
friends and when I got out of college he
said well you know I'm right for this
show called space stars and they had
Space Ghost it was a hanna-barbera and
he asked if I'd like to collaborate them
because he was writing all the episodes
and and I said sure and and then we
wrote for Smurfs together and that was
very clearly like to write these on my
own so I just started writing animation
and I rose very quickly in animation but
my heart really wasn't that wasn't my
one to be so I then turned enough to
live for the year for my writing
animation I can earn about $100,000 in
three months which is a lot back then
and because I was the god of animation I
was doing very very well in that arena
and and I stole all my employers that I
was going to take time off to write this
live-action screenplay and I wouldn't be
available they said great and the day I
stopped to write the screenplay they
started calling me with offers of
animation work and I had to turn down
$200,000 in two days in that wreck show
riding day so then from then on I wrote
at UCLA where they couldn't reach me it
was before cellphones and I would just
check my answering machine at the end of
the day so I could write and I finished
that screenplay and it's sold and it got
me
highlighted with NBC and that pilot got
made and I was off and running in
live-action writing for the networks and
the studios so my point in that is you
must take a stand free where you're
going and what you believe and even if
you're doing well
you if it's not your dream you must take
a stand to be willing to take the licks
take the blows and be willing to to take
the losses in addition but at the point
that I was getting out before that is
because I appeared our surgeon mentoring
me that led to me Mike meeting Michael
Reeves was a professional who brought me
into television so it wasn't me writing
spec scripts and trying to get an agent
to take me or anything like that it was
someone opening a door for me through a
friendship through that but I also you
know I could write so and at the same
time I was writing The Twilight Zone
companion at 22 to because when I got
out of UCLA UCLA I knew I wanted to be a
writer producer in television there were
no classes in that so I thought well how
do I learned this and I said well why
don't I think one of the greatest shows
ever made and learn how it was made and
then by emulating the people who made it
I can do that job I can learn that job
so it was two years after Rod Serling's
death and I was 22 years old I'd sold
one short story if I'd asked a hundred
people how how likely it was that Rod
Serling's Widow would let me write that
book a hundred people would have said no
no you have no chance which is why your
future in your career is not a majority
opinion it's your opinion and what I did
was because she'd already turned down
major journalists and so I couldn't go
directly to her she'd have said no so
what I did was I met one writer who
worked on the Twilight Zone in a science
fiction convention so I interviewed him
his name was George Clayton Johnson and
I asked him who he knew that I could
also interview so he connect me up with
a couple of people and they connected me
up with a couple of people and over
three months maybe even 30 people who
had worked on The Twilight Zone
by then I knew a lot about the subject I
felt very confident I could pull this
off and then I went to Carol Serling and
it was at rods house it was exactly as
he left it there was one room just for
the awards it was
Sammis the Peabody Awards the three
hugo's and there were two living rooms
there was an Olympic sized pool his
office was a building back in the house
all the books were there all scrapbooks
the film's Kansas's Twilight Zone
episode 60 millimeter prints and film
cans sack high in the garage and then
upstairs in the attic were his
scrapbooks his scripts his files
I literally crawl through Ralston Rod
Serling's attic which was great and but
but after three months I met with Carol
Sterling and I stood there and I told
her she was sitting I was standing and I
just kind of pitched what I was going to
do and then she must have talked to the
people I'd interviewed who she trusted
they said well this kid only thing he
and pull it off and she didn't said you
have full access to everything and I
went to where all the scrapbooks all the
files everything I interviewed over a
hundred people the book came out it was
a huge success it's still imprinted sold
over half a million copies and the New
York Times named it one of ten science
fiction books for the ages in 2006 and I
was the only non-fiction book on that
list so Ray Bradbury and I were on that
list so it's so much fun to go over to
raise that day and say hey we're both on
this list in the New York Times that was
just as a great moment
you